[Musique]
vous appelez lara dans le famille croft
l'art à ton père nous a quittés tu
pourrais prendre sa relève
vous vous ressemblez tellement
ingénieux salut ma puce
si tu écoutes ce message c'est sans
doute que je suis mort j'ai découvert
quelque chose
un tombeau appelé la mère de la mort si
le projet de la trinité abouti notre
monde est en danger promets moi de les
arrêter
je te le promets
je crois savoir où mon père est allé
c'est juste au milieu de la mer du
diable ce serait une aventure
la mort n'a rien d'une aventure
[Musique]
vous n'auriez pas dû venir mais je suis
heureux que vous soyez là
qu'est ce que vous savez de mon père je
vois la ressemblance entre vendre la
témérité ferme le tombeau à tout jamais
le sort de l'humanité est entre tes
mains
[Musique]
il faut être très prudent de nos jours
le monde est complètement malade je vais
en prendre deux